because they know, they must know their
history, history is born and is being made
now, this is their age, this is what they will
tell their children. I don't want
them to not know something. I want them to
see what the horror of war is,
and we are now showing the whole world what
we have  it's not just faith, we also know how to
fight for him, this is the most important thing, and this is the
result of this struggle,
this is a long, long time, you know, I'm
sorry
psychologically, it's hard for me
[music]
already six months have passed, of course, I
want it to be as soon as possible, the war is
over Well, we need time for this, we need
understand
guys are holding on It's good We believe that
we will win 6 months it's sad that
blood is pouring and all that but we're holding on
it's good